these are weird times we're living in
we're very hung up on everybody's sexual
orientation these days you know like
transgender what do you think
it's a tough one yeah that's a hot
button issue people get worked up you
always see the guy on the news gender
neutral bathroom should be a man and a
woman I don't want to sit next to a
trans person it's like whoa dude I don't
next to anybody
but I've never thought about the type of
person I'm sitting next to who's got
time to decipher someone's background
when you got to take a dump if I get
diarrhea at a restaurant I run in the
bathroom I'm not like oh no a Puerto
Rican ah
I can't take a BM next to a PR what the
hell
I do agree there should be two bathrooms
though not divided by gender I think
it's divided by pissing I don't
really care who I'm next to as
long as they're also right but
I'll tell you this if I walk into the
room and I see a trans person piss
I'm gonna go hey you better transition
to a right now
you're in the wrong room sister
brother whatever